[Music]
then come here news bit of bite tips
brains are pretty well it's not even
there no more
I know I don't have that I know I got
the brains a homeless woman with meth in
her bra
Lord to little boys with candy what in
the [ __ ] does that have to do with
anything
smells like la what does the meth have
to do with pedophilia
I don't did initiate pedophile cut know
what she's just trying to like she's
only let me tell you the story please
because I am mixed no I'll turn on the
meth head lady what candy was she
turning Marvin candy two little boys
didn't set the room
what kind of candy it was reported as a
chocolate card the hell many kids know
why bro coulda got me as a kid I would
have been like you I hate chocolate same
I wasn't I didn't have a sweetness so
you would have to lure me with like
liking pop or something oh yeah they
coulda lured me with fruit watermelon
citizen booze no this big place and
Dallas not last so there was this
homeless woman that's how accidents
happen [ __ ] you David
nobody struck will be at the end why is
the point what why no all right
oh my see that explains why I've been to
some iron what you're lucky you have a
David uses a fork to cut a steak in feed
himself with a knife cannot own a gun
your weapon is this [ __ ] wooden sword
I could just like your dream yes I did
we will not let you have a gun during a
box yeah she added I got my good life is
these tears in house no you don't know
you are the camp cook you're lucky we
let you try it nobody even want me to
let you drive because the car drives
itself he has a [ __ ] Tesla that's the
only reason why you can drive I'll tell
you what I'm only fell down my list
there's three times
you're [ __ ] dangerous I slept on them
burgers two three times midnight is not
that bad [ __ ] scary
everybody just okay so shoulders come on
them anyway hold goddess is hurt
so this homeless woman her name is
castle special 23 years old that's a
cool name what is not in Cass I mean
that one name is really young and an
object look at how she looked at whoa
why does she look like she's 50 to mess
23 maybe that's a typo maybe just
looking 30 too many smokes a lot of bad
things and he looks like an ogre hey
boys you want some chocolate
so we're suited is she approached this
apartment complex where there were two
little boys aged five and six no okay I
could see why you wanted to be a lord
fight yeah cuz you're so young so she
approached them and she said that she'd
buy them food and water and whatever
they want if they followed her probably
like [ __ ] water no I'm in like with
candy - she like entice them a lot candy
I don't want to be mean but B pairs of
this children you have failed because
Dyna ghibli the first thought I had that
is a simple thing that you should teach
your kids at a very early age
stranger danger you watch your kids when
they're playing outside yeah and you
said I bet you these kids I mean
logically perfect yes why I always
played outside with no one watching it
me two different times at five yeah
that's really odd not my personal four
we know is not some Alana things but
you're supposed to I played outside by
myself when I was like nine my mom
thought the world was a very safe place
my neighborhood was pretty safe though
yeah so then these kids followed her to
the there nearby Walmart which is about
a mile away
oh she the people Walmart for sure they
were inside the Walmart and she went
shoplifting with them so she was
teaching them how to shop with us don't
life-skills Superman yeah so anyways to
the Boy Scouts or shoplifting so then
police were called they arrested Castle
and when they searched her they found a
clear bag
with crystal meth tucked in her bra her
bosoms yeah oh oh I hate oh no nice to
work in my parents daughter and regular
bacon oh I know you're going to go what
I'll talk I had those two and it's
[ __ ] sticky and wet but let me tell
you this right here huh let me show you
different line on a time like really
science is you already know okay Felton
girl let me tell you two about hell then
one [ __ ] I will remember for the rest
of my life she didn't have cash then
[ __ ] cat 12 quarters entertaining what
we're thinking I don't know the exact
number but she went and then she [ __ ]
dug change out onto my counter Oh [ __ ]
police lady oh my god it was just so
disgusting cuz in number one yes she
wasn't wearing a shirt well she just
came out in her bra holy dude just a med
big ass didn't stop it I told me to
[ __ ] count it
I was mortified yeah I never got changed
but we would get ladies at the bank that
I just didn't want to do online like
bill pay so they would come and pay
their credit card statements like with
me at the teller booth and then they
would like get digging too because they
always have big tits for some reason
because I know when I was flat-chested
before [ __ ] boobs like I couldn't
carry [ __ ] in my bra so we just fall
right through but they're always big to
the ladies and then she would get this
she call like this but to take this - my
money go she's like digging up my
wonderful going to hear that yet if
you'd had like a roll of money and oh
yes you've been walking all day so it's
like moist like haze no smell it no
whole row home and I did up the grab and
like oh thanks net the counting I don't
want to be a [ __ ] so I'm just like this
yeah it's wet it's gross any fun you'll
be surprised how much [ __ ] those tits
can hold a lot
it is crazy if I hold on a second Wow
you know those og cell phones like
douche take this this is like this like
oh hold up it's crazy David my old [ __ ]
hold on second like what's all that
possibly IDs Jeremy way of you oh oh
[Laughter]
[ __ ] come on [ __ ] he'll be out me yes
do you think that wasn't something that
happen every now and then too it
happened often on that side I had to
deal with it a lot and it was just yeah
Teddy juice on the counter yes I had
titties now I wouldn't have to have a
fanny pack
yeah your fanny packs will be right here
mm-hmm yes anyways and I would have a
lot of fun woman she got arrested and
two children were safely returned to
their mothers who had already called 911
searching for the kid what was she
planning on doing with these kids I
think she just wanted some friends maybe
she just like you know how like people
have those monkeys that pickpocket for
more like Ferris Oh wanted those two
little chimpanzee boys to go out and
grab some stuff and come back and I
really remember what I was telling you
though this is what we should do for
either teaching about a steal no we
should we have to get somebody as a
hired actor to lure Isaac to see what he
does and when Isaac goes into the band
and he find it were they're saying yeah
[ __ ] your ass up what the [ __ ] did we
just tell you here's a YouTube channel
that does that
oh really yeah there's terrible yeah
mine is a joke huh well just kryptonite
levels I don't know anymore no more
series probably anymore what if Bruno
Mars himself goes when a comment were
left different Irie man I'll go and call
dr. van der Meyde pointing up you may be
feeling I feel like if I was a child I'd
be abducted by Michael Jackson parkour
oh yeah shantel for sure yeah if he
pulls up in the limo and he's like want
to go to Neverland Oh
yo bust my [ __ ] family let's do
it that's a bit hard to say though
because number one he's a celebrity you
know I you would as a kid
if you idolize this guy I say I would
never leave no but he has Neverland
my mom has a [ __ ] chance alive I
don't care I don't mess with the trans
la like that [ __ ]
for real I should hurt he's magical I
believed everything I was like at noon
Walker yeah when I had the crush on bad
guys and all that stuff
leave that movie to I when I was really
young I'm like me you know how everybody
says that he's a molester and [ __ ] but
in the movie it proves that he's
actually the one protecting the children
from molesters and pedophiles oh don't
touch him that's my job hey hey we saw
the evidence what evidence - remember
they released all the photos of his
place yeah there was nothing that
pointed to him being I'm still with some
crazy
we talked around jaehee news there was a
development of that I remember what
happened it's a lie yeah it's a lot he's
a child and and that's why he likes
child pain at the Peter Pan syndrome
he's a child
you know Peter Pan so Jimmy got baby
dick syndrome he's a child
he's not [ __ ] children she never was
I believed him if I have to say that
Bill Cosby is a rapist that's different
that wasn't proven in the court of law
drugs when I multiple Y all say both of
them were wrong oh come on can't say
both are wrong Michael Jackson never was
proven wrong yeah guilty and there's
even people and bodyguards that know
them guilty
there's even bodyguards and people that
have known Michael for a long long time
that say no way Jose but there are
people coming out from Bill Cosby saying
yes way Jose there are kids that are
saying that he touched them with greedy
parents we happened kind of like greedy
on TV ladies - they could say that penis
yeah so there's like a slippery slope
with that - nah I'm saying though you
can't see [ __ ] until I see some proof
Michael is it no more proof with Bill
Cosby either yeah there is no they're
just people just people accusing no I
believe it I'm saying I believe both I
don't I'm really bad Bill Cosby is
Minister Michael Jackson is Minister
what do priests do to little children no
no priests ministers are different they
have wives give me the [ __ ] anyways
Castle has been charged with saving kids
yeah
it's two charges of unlawful restraint
of a minor saving kids bus off and one
count of substance possession and one
counts of property theft under $30,000
and you know for all you people out
there that want to do meth
look at this bitch's face I'm pretty
sure the people that want to do meth
don't know that they want to do meth and
if they've already tried it they're not
watching them I'm just but just in case
if you don't want your face to look like
the moon and our [ __ ] craters
anywhere and look like you're 40 years
older don't know mess seriously this
girl looks like she's a [ __ ] pro
boxer that never puts up her hands yeah
like MMA fight not know how to block
well yeah my biggest never ever told her
about that part of boxing thank you
don't you mess Kim hey guys thanks for
watching that last episode if you
haven't already make sure to hit that
subscribe button because we upload
videos every single day for you guys now
to watch more videos check them out of
here
[Music]
[Music]